[Music]
foreign
gets a special prosecutor it's the
biggest most beautiful specialist
Council anyone has ever seen no one's
ever seen a prosecutor quite so special
grown men were Weeping at the sight of
this Council uh that joke never gets old
in a Friday after the midterms news dump
attorney general Merrick Garland
announced that he has appointed a
special counsel to conduct two criminal
investigations related to Donald Trump
this is extremely big news that has so
far kind of flown under the radar but in
all likelihood this means big things in
a super abundance of caution the
attorney general has decided that the
Department of Justice can't investigate
the former president because he's
running for president again and it would
look political and isn't it sort of like
double jeopardy in the old days they
used to call it double jeopardy enter
the special counsel no not that guy
you're not that guy pal trust me you're
not that guy this guy Jack Smith should
Donald Trump celebrate does this mean
that there will be a few more years of
trump escaping Justice or the
prosecutions are just around the Horizon
well by all accounts attorney general
mayor Garland is an institutionalist
those that want to see a former
president put in jail have criticized
Garland for being too slow and too
methodical or just not doing anything
and although some Republicans predicted
that garland would use his office to
exact some kind of Revenge on
Republicans the opposite has largely
been true it appears that Garland
decided not to prosecute Matt Gates or
Rudy Giuliani and now Garland has issued
an order to appoint John L Smith to
serve as special counsel for the
Department of Justice to conduct two
ongoing investigations related to the
former president Trump whether Trump
unlawfully interfered with the 2020
presidential election and the
certification of the Electoral College
vote on January 6 and whether Trump
broke any laws when he removed
classified documents in other
presidential records from the White
House to Mar-A-Lago now Congress has
delegated the authority of the Attorney
General to appoint a special counsel 28
USC 510 says the Attorney General May
from time to time make such Provisions
as he considers appropriate authorizing
the performance by any other officer
employee or agency of the Department of
Justice of any function of the Attorney
General but the special counsel does
have real Independence under CFR section
600.7 the special counsel shall not be
subject to the day-to-day supervision of
any official of the department however
the Attorney General May request the
special counsel provide an explanation
for any investigative or prosecutorial
step and may after a review conclude
that the action was so inappropriate or
unwarranted under established
environmental practices that it should
not be pursued in concluding that review
the Attorney General will give great
weight to the views of the special
counsel if the Attorney General
concludes that a proposed action by a
special counsel should not be pursued
the Attorney General shall notify
Congress and that section goes on to
explain that the special counsel can
only be removed for cause now Garland's
order is broader with respect to the
first issue the certification over the
Electoral College vote quote the special
counsel is authorized to conduct the
ongoing investigation into whether any
person or entity violated the law in
connection with efforts to interfere
with the lawful transfer of power
following the 2020 presidential election
or the certification of the Electoral
College vote held on or about January 6
2021 as well as any matters that arose
or might arise directly from this
investigation or that are within the
scope of 28 CFR section
600.4 A and continues this authorization
does not apply to prosecutions that are
currently pending in the District of
Columbia as well as future
investigations and prosecutions of
individuals for offenses they committed
while physically present on the capital
grounds on January 6 2021. that means
that people who were on the capitol
grounds will continue to be prosecuted
by the doj with the involvement of the
special counsel that means that the
normies who are not in Trump's Inner
Circle who were on the capital grounds
will continue to be prosecuted by the
doj without the involvement of the
special counsel the special counsel will
be looking at the role that Trump and
others who were not of the capital but
who were scheming for ways for him to
stay in office and as we've seen this is
a fairly complicated investigation that
encompasses the plot to use fake
electors in multiple States it could
also include investigation of people who
planned the January 6 protest which
could lead higher up the chain and the
special counsel order does not impact
ongoing state and local investigations
such as the Fulton County's probe into
the fake elector plot there's currently
a grand jury considering evidence in
that case right now with possible
defendants including Donald Trump and
Senator Lindsey Graham the special
counsel will also take over the
investigation into the Mar-A-Lago
documents quote the special counsel is
further authorized to conduct the
ongoing investigation referenced and
described in the United States response
to motion for judicial oversight and
additional relief Donald J Trump vs
United States as well as any matters
that arose or may arise directly from
this investigation or that are within
the scope of 28 CFR 600.4 a so the
question is why a special counsel the
special or indented council at the
federal level has been around in one
form or another for almost 150 years the
First Independent Council was appointed
by President Ulysses S Grant to
investigate corruption at the high level
of federal government officials in his
administration and just how independent
these special prosecutors were dependent
on the laws governing their appointment
after the Fallout from Watergate
Congress passed the ethics and
Government Act of 1978 Which authorized
the appointment of independent councils
under the act the Attorney General would
conduct an initial investigation to
determine and whether an independent
investigation was warranted if it was
then a three-judge panel of federal
judges would appoint an independent
Council that act was used to investigate
Bill Clinton initially for his
Whitewater real estate deals which
eventually turned into an investigation
over his affair with Monica Lewinsky and
obstruction of justice in 1999 the
statute expired and Congress did not
reauthorize it in part because Democrats
probably believe that the independent
Council was a little too independent but
obviously there was still a need for an
independent investigative process so in
1999 the doj promulgated regulations to
establish procedures for the appointment
of special counsels pursuant to the
attorney general's General
administrative hiring Authority special
counsel serve a similar role as
independent councils but they have less
Independence the Attorney General
generally has the authority to appoint
supervise and remove them that said we
have an example where that kind of
Independence was directly challenged
Richard Nixon's attorney general Elliot
Richardson hired Archibald Cox as a
special prosecutor relating to the
Watergate Affair the AG had sole
authority to fire Cox and only four
extraordinary improprieties but Nixon
eventually tied tired of the
investigation and ordered Richardson to
fire Cox Richardson famously refused and
immediately resigned Nixon then ordered
Deputy Attorney General William ruckel's
house to fire Cox ruggle's house refused
and also resigned Nixon finally ordered
solicitor general Robert Bork the number
three the doj to fire Cox and bork
complied the special prosecutor was out
of a job so while the modern special
counsel regulations contemplate
Independence it's hard to refuse the
head of the Executive Branch the special
counsel is funded by the independent
Council appropriation a permanent
indefinite appropriation established in
the Justice Department's 1988
Appropriations act and that means that
the money comes from a permanent
Treasury Department account and isn't
subject to the annual Appropriations
process and the Attorney General
controls the special counsel budget so
Congress can't defund jack Smith in this
case the special counsel reports
directly to the AG and if he determines
that say Donald Trump should be charged
the special counsel has to notify
attorney general Garland the regulation
says quote the special counsel shall
notify the Attorney General of events in
the course of his or her invest
destigation and Conformity with the
departmental guidelines with respect to
Urgent reports Congress also has the
right to know what the special counsel
is doing the regulation says quote the
Attorney General will notify the
chairman ranking minority member of the
Judiciary Committees of each house of
Congress with an explanation for each
action one upon appointing a special
counsel to upon removing any special
counsel and three upon conclusion of the
special counsel's investigation
including to the extent consistent with
applicable law a description and
explanation of instances if any in which
the Attorney General concluded that a
proposed action by a special counsel was
so inappropriate or unwarranted
underestablished departmental practices
that it should not be pursued so
Congress will be notified about the
outcome of the trump-related
investigations but another question why
a special counsel now although some have
questioned whether Garland made the
right decision the regulations seemed to
contemplate a situation like this it
states that the Attorney General will
appoint a special counsel to conduct
certain investigations or prosecutions
and those regulations are set forth in
28 CFR 600.1 which establishes is a
three-part analysis for determining
whether to appoint a special counsel
first the Attorney General must
determine that quote a criminal
investigation of a person or matter is
warranted then the Attorney General must
determine whether the investigation or
prosecution of the person or matter by
the U.S attorney's office or a justice
department litigating division would
present either a conflict of interest
for the department or an extraordinary
circumstance third the Attorney General
must consider whether it would be in the
public interest to appoint an outside
special counsel to assume responsibility
in the matter so while Garland's order
doesn't specify on what grounds he
appointed Smith in his speech announcing
the appointment he said quote based on
recent developments including the former
president's announcement that he is a
candidate for president in the next
election and the sitting president's
stated intention to be a candidate as
well
I have concluded that it is in the
public interest to appoint a special
counsel and in the next breath he points
out that Donald Trump had announced his
candidacy to become president again and
President Biden had indicated that he
would run for re-election so those might
indicate either an extraordinary
circumstance or a conflict of interest
between the sitting president and a
potential future president though on the
other hand there's an argument that
there's no actual conflict of interest
that would preclude the doj from
handling investigations normally just
like they did before President Trump
announced he was running for president
he is after all just a U.S citizen at
this point Garland has been overseeing
the investigation into the events of
January 6 for two years and any
perceived conflict might have already
existed during that time and yet there
was no special counsel at that point
though certainly appointing Smith as
special counsel has not eliminated
political criticism Senator Ted Cruz
said that the timing of the appointment
was proof that the investigation was
politically motivated Cruz said quote
three days ago Trump announced and now
there is a special counsel this is Trump
derangement syndrome but this time with
a gun and a badge meanwhile the house
Judiciary Committee attacks Miss
impartiality quote Jack Smith and his
buddies have been politicizing
Washington for ages and he's who A.G
Garland picked to be the special counsel
to in quote investigate president Trump
come on and on the other end of the
spectrum people who believe that Trump
committed crimes and got away with them
have scoffed at the appointment of a
special counsel they contend that this
investigation will end the way that the
Mueller investigation did with a report
rather than a prosecution though this
doesn't seem to be totally accurate
first of all the Mueller investigation
did lead to 34 people and three
companies to be indicted and of course
president Trump was not one of those
people but there are reasons for that
you can certainly disagree with them but
there were reasons the attorney general
has sole authority to determine the
scope of the special counsel's inquiry
and then president Trump's attorney's
General wanted to limit the special
counsel's work and under the Mandate and
Mueller's interpretation of that mandate
Mueller was not allowed to accuse
president Trump of a crime now Mueller
was also constrained by the office of
legal counsel memo that says a sitting
president cannot be indicted while he's
in office that momentum's conclusion is
controversial and this Supreme Court has
never ruled on that however the justice
department employees do follow the olc
memo so the Mueller report outlined over
10 instances of obstruction of justice
that implicated Trump however even if
Mueller had the authority to charge
Trump he believed that he was bound by
the olc guidance on indicting sitting
presidents the Smith appointment as
special counsel is markedly different
because Garland gave him a broad mandate
to investigate and prosecute Trump if
the evidence is there the posture of the
case is also very different there were
multiple grand juries weighing evidence
that Trump interfered with the
certification of the 2020 election and
that he broke the law by taking
documents to Mar-A-Lago in addition
there's no memorandum or court case
anywhere that suggests it's illegal to
prosecute an ex-president and Smith will
have to follow doj's guidance on when it
is appropriate to recommend criminal
charges section
9-27.220 of the doj's manual outlines
the grounds for commencing or declining
prosecution it states quote the attorney
for the government should commence or
recommend Federal prosecution if he she
believes that the person's conduct
constitutes a federal offense and that
the admissible evidence will probably be
sufficient to obtain and sustain a
conviction unless one the prosecution
would serve no substantial Federal
interest two the person is subject to
effective prosecution in another
jurisdiction or three there exists an
adequate non-criminal alternative to
prosecution so now you might be
wondering who is Jack Smith the new
special counsel well he is a 50 year old
graduate of Harvard Law School who
started his career as a prosecutor in
the Manhattan District Attorney's Office
Smith then moved to the U.S attorney's
Office in Brooklyn where he worked on
public corruption cases Smith then spent
two years as the investigation
coordinator in the office of the
prosecutor at the international criminal
court in The Hague Smith supervised
high-profile investigations that people
wanted for war crimes and genocide from
2010 to 2015 Smith was chief of the
doj's public Integrity section which
investigates public corruption
allegations and while in that role Smith
investigated high-profile politicians on
both sides of the aisle which really
seemed to piss off just about everyone
the public Integrity section was Under
Fire for a case against former Senator
Ted Stevens which collapsed during
Smith's first few months on the job he
closed investigations into several
Republican members of Congress during
his years as Chief the public Integrity
section garnered a successful conviction
against former Republican Governor Bob
McDonald which was later unanimously
overturned by the Supreme Court and then
the Obama Administration chose not to
continue prosecution after that reversal
Smith also pursued a case against
Democratic vice presidential candidate
and former Senator John Edwards which
resulted in a hung jury in a mistrial
Smith also helped lead the investigation
into Democrat Bob Menendez though he
left the department a few months before
the indictment though Menendez was later
acquitted his team won a conviction
against representative Rick renzi a
republican from Arizona who was
sentenced to three years in prison
though Trump pardoned renzi right before
he left office in early 2021. for Zone
part Smith said that the pace of the
Trump investigations would not slow down
under his watch he said quote I intend
to conduct the assigned investigations
and any prosecutions that may result
from them independently and in the best
traditions of the Department of Justice
Mr Smith said that in a statement he
vowed that the investigations would move
forward expeditiously quote to whatever
outcome the facts and law dictate though
the New York Times reports that Smith
quote will remain in the Netherlands for
some time according to the justice
department in order to recover from a
recent bicycle accident though the 11
circuit held oral arguments in the
Mar-A-Lago case on the Tuesday before
Thanksgiving and although Smith remains
overseas the doj filed noticed that he
was on the case quote special counsel
Smith has reviewed the filings in this
litigation and approves all of the
arguments that have been presented in
the briefs and will be discussed at the
oral argument in this case a special
counsel Smith's name will be affixed to
Future pleadings filed in all matters
falling within his appointment so while
the appointment of Jack Smith as special
counsel gives a little bit for everyone
to hate net net it's probably not good
news for former president Trump
certainly it probably means delays in
the short term but Jack Smith has an
advantage over Robert Mueller who had to
hire investigators and prosecutors and
start from scratch Smith gets to hit the
ground running he'll supervise doj
prosecutors who are already on the case
and the doj has issued subpoenas served
a search warrant on Mar-A-Lago and are
in court battling Trump over the
appointment of the special mass faster
and a special counsel has hit the ground
running Smith now oversees the ongoing
investigation into Trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 election and Smith's
office just issued subpoenas to
elections officials in Allegheny County
Pennsylvania Dane County Wisconsin Wayne
County Michigan and Maricopa County
Arizona The subpoena seek documents and
Communications they had with 19 people
including Trump and some of his most
well-known Associates like Looney lawyer
Lynn wood Sidney the Kraken Powell Rudy
Giuliani cleta Mitchell and Bernie
Carrick realistically the appointment of
Smith probably does nothing to mollify
the political critics of it who will say
that this is a political prosecution but
still appointing a special counsel is
probably still better than Maine justice
under the Aegis of A.G Garland doing the
prosecution and while trying to figure
out what's going to happen next is
reading tea leaves it probably doesn't
mean that nothing is going to happen in
other words Garland probably would not
have appointed a special counsel if he
had determined that no prosecution was
warranted and I think that Smith's
experience shows that he prosecutes hard
cases often the doj will only take a
case if they think that they are sure to
win but it looks like Smith's record
doesn't follow that adage public
Integrity cases are notoriously
difficult and the reason that the
Supreme Court has overturned some of
these convictions is That Drawing the
Line Between political action and
bribery is very tough to do let alone to
get convictions in these politically
sensitive cases though here at least
with respect to documents that is a much
much simpler case than political bribery
but while special counsel Smith is
resting his bicycle injury and getting
up to speed he'll want some legal
audiobooks to listen to he might enjoy
John grisham's new legal thriller the
judge's list on today's sponsor audible
it's all about a judge who is also a
serial killer and uses the law against
his investigators because a killer who
knows how to manipulate the legal system
is the scariest killer of all
now I use Audible almost every day and
it's by far the best source of audio
entertainment I listen to audiobooks
when I'm running cleaning up or when I'm
supposed to be listening to friends and
loved ones audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
all in one place if you tried to listen
to everything it would take you three
centuries and as an audible member
you'll get one credit every month that
you can use on any title in their entire
premium catalog that includes basically
every bestseller new release or Memoir
those titles are yours to keep forever
in your audible library and you'll also
get full access to their popular plus
catalog which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audiobooks original
entertainment guided Fitness and
meditation sleep tracks and shows all
are included with your membership no
credits needed and right now audible is
running a special promo new audible
members get a free one-month trial you
can try it out and see why everyone
loves audible all you have to do is go
to audible.com legal eagle or click on
the link that's on screen right now or
in the description so right now for a
limited time get a free one month trial
of audible by clicking on the link below
and after that click on this box over
here for more legal eagle or I'll see
you in court